tear down waltz of ignorance and
narrow-mindedness
for nothing has to stay as it is it was
one of several standing ovations for the
German Chancellor during her keynote
speech she ended and began in English
highly unusual for Angela Merkel at such
a major event if we step out and embrace
new beginnings everything is possible
for the normally cautious pragmatic
politician this was a far-reaching to-do
list she spoke of halting global warming
eradicating starvation eliminating
diseases giving people especially girls
access to education and fighting the
causes of displacement and forced
migration we can do all of that the
Harvard commencement speech is by
tradition inspirational setting the bar
high for graduating students Merkel
urged them not to act impulsively but to
take a moment to stop and think drawing
laughter as well as applause more than
once Merkel teamed to conjure up Donald
Trump without mention of his name
that means not calling lies truth or
truth lies the Chancellor's mixture of
the political and the aspirational
seemed to resonate with the graduating
students for me the main message is
about believing that's walls can be
broken and for me I think a wall as sort
of a metaphor for anything it could be
sort of your own closed mindedness or
your own set of ambivalence to how you
see the issues of the world whether you
know whether or not you think they could
be solved I think the speech was very
well done and well received and I think
that she's struck a balance between
inspiring the graduates to make change
in the world and also sending a
political message
Merkel has made it clear this is her
last term as Chancellor and her speech
was a nod to the legacy she hopes to
leave behind especially a firm
commitment to strong transatlantic ties
not earning returned Oh Simon was still
with me our political correspondent
Simon angler making made some very
pointed remarks during her commencement
address they're warning against snap
decisions and impulsive action how do
you think that's going to play in into
talks with the talks with Mike Pompeo
the secretary of state of the United
States who's here for the first time his
official visit yeah I mean those were
very pointed remarks she didn't actually
mention president Trump but I think
everyone in the audience understood that
that was what she was talking about with
those talking about snap decision making
and also really criticizing broadly
American foreign policy talking about
isolationism
and you know setting up boundaries right
where what you need to do is find common
solutions multilateralism was it was a
plea for that really a speech we've
heard from Angela Merkel many times
before I don't think it changes exactly
the dynamic of course as I say Pompeo is
the one who's chosen the timing of their
meeting today so it's just unfortunate
for him but that you know it's come
after this rather pointed speech from
the Chancellor in America and obviously
it'll add a little extra spice to those
conversations absolutely and as we saw
that the speech was really well received
by the students at Harvard now it also
give her a big platform to address
certain issues which are very close to
her heart yeah I mean she was receiving
the honorary degree from Harvard for her
via Schaaf and a so sort of can-do
attitude on migration and her openness
to welcome refugees into Germany of
course highly controversial policy so
I'm not sure if the university is aware
of all the nuances around that policy
that still plague Angela Merkel here but
there is a sense in which Angela
Merkel's on the sort of home straight of
her chancellorship she won't be standing
again of course as we know she's got a
couple of years at most to run and I
think she's sort of drawing together
these stray
of her worldview multilateralism the
battle against climate change but also a
sort of respectful approach in dealing
with other worldviews that's what she
was playing for right Sammy yang DWS
political correspondent thank you very
much for your analysis